pierre est frustré les six qu'il a
acheté biais de rendre l'âme après
seulement neuf mois d'utilisation
heureusement qu'il a conservé sa facture
mais horreur
ils découvrent qu'elles étaient faciles
alors comment faire pour honorer la
garantie d'un an sans facture ce ne sera
pas facile pour claire de faire valoir
sa garantie et comme la loi n'oblige pas
les commerçants à fournir des factures
qui dure c'est encore nous qui devons
prendre nos précautions
la recommandation de l'office de
protection du consommateur ces factures
qui s'efface et dont vous pourriez avoir
besoin photocopié ou alors numérisés
l'est pendant qu'il est encore temps
joignez la copie à l'original et ranger
le tout ici en plus vous avez votre
relevé de transactions de carte bancaire
ou d'un crédit
vous aurez plus de chance de faire
valoir vos droits le fin mot de
l'histoire de nos jours plus rien et
durable prévoyez de coûts